my stepdad was the most wonderful dad
like I call him my dad don't call my
stepdad because he raised me you know so
he's still with us no he passed away
like five years ago oh how hard was that
that was tough because he was such he
was the first person to encourage me to
do acting because my mom was very
traditional was wonderful in the
traditional Mexican mother sense where
she's like you have to be at you know
like a lawyer or a doctor and I was like
why are those always a two professions
like it's just like why are the hardest
professions the ones that you cheer he
doesn't choose it's I think that she
wants you know she sacrificed a lot to
you know come to this country and and
for her Offspring to choose and I would
be an actor and it's like well you know
yeah yeah that's not the most stable
because it isn't this if you feel a
responsibility almost to her to to
pursue those things no not in a way
because I've always been stubborn and I
was always like when she would tell me
like you know she never said I couldn't
do it she just discouraged me to do it
she said because when I fell in love
with acting was I saw Annie for the
first time on yeah I read that yeah yeah
and I was watching this I thought it was
a movie or a TV show I didn't know it
was a movie so we didn't go to the movie
theaters that was rich people did that
like it was a movie wow so you were
really poor we're really bored yeah and
I was like I thought this was a new TV
show during my Christmas break so I
couldn't understand what the episodes
were so back
and they're just cohesive yeah they're
like wow this is really well edited
the brakes are seamless
brick and it comes back where I picked
up I was like this is good that's good
writing it's a really good [ __ ]
writing and um I told my mom I fell in
love with it because these kids were
poor dancing and singing and I was like
oh my gosh mom I want to be that when I
grow up I want to be an orphan
oh
and so you met it I want to be an actor
and literally I was just like so I told
her well how do I become an actor and
she said that's for rich kids and I was
like you gotta be rich to play poor on
television that makes no sense and then
she goes no I mean they take acting
classes dancing and voice and all that
and we don't have money for that and I
was like so I was kind of discouraged
then but she soldered my face and she
said I didn't see you couldn't do it I
said that we can't pay for that but if
you find your way Miko you can do
whatever you want you can do whatever
you want what's that mean if you find
your own way my son like my son oh it's
like a nice Swift San Antonio like sun
like sun
um you can do whatever you want and I
said okay fine because I'm six years old
and I know what to do with my life uh
and we were walking home from school one
day and I found out that at the local
community center they're doing like an
improv class and there was like 12.50
how old are you this is six you're like
six years old and the my fellow thespian
at school because we would reenact the
Disney Channel thing with the wand right
like hi I'm Harvey King you're watching
Disney Channel and mines would never
look good like I think you can edit this
and maybe it gets whatever I'm drawing
because it does not look like anything
uh so we were practicing we want we
thought we got on Disney Channel you
could be an actor so that was our ticket
in so we're like we're gonna be on
Disney Channel we just have to take
acting classes and then she found out
there was an acting class at a local
community center and it was 50 cents for
improv class so two dollars and fifty
cents twelve dollars twelve dollars and
I was just like I went to my mom and I
was like can I have the money she's like
no because we have money for that and I
was like she went to her parents and
they gave her 20. and I was like so I
started teaching me like the gap of like
you know uh generational wealth where it
was like my mom was struggling just to
keep us you know alive and how lucky was
that my friend could go to her parents
you know who uh were already paid off
with their mortgage already you know
what I mean or like whatever uh had a
well education uh degree job what not
and so I was like I don't understand the
difference here and so I was like I had
to find other way I have to get that
money